Melonhead hey guys I'm a huge fan of
Tiger Valley and Bobby Lee in general my
name is Jonathan Nogueira I'm 25 year
old undefeated pro MMA fighter I've had
the most terrible luck in my dating life
this year or so it seems like every
chick I've dated Lily has only been
interested in me because the fact that I
fight only I came to the point where I
don't even tell people I fight which
resulted in me now getting no attention
at all by any ladies what can I do to
find someone who actually cares about me
as a person than just wanting to be with
me because I'm a fighter
Oh PS how would you guys like to come to
my next MMA fight and Bobby how would
you like to be a part of my corner you
have to be like a corner I would love to
be on your corner boyfriend oh I want to
say this right now to you my friend my
team and my friend Jonathan Johnny that
every girl is with their guy for some
reason exterior reason either the way
they look what they do for a living
all those things come into play kalila
doesn't agree with me but I know for a
fact I don't disagree
I wouldn't she wouldn't be with me if I
worked at Home Depot no I wouldn't be
with you if you made the exact amount of
money but I thought you were a shitty
comedian I cannot be with someone who's
not great at their current right so
that's another thing it because it makes
money that's another thing so he's
undefeated
which is what the thing is he's
undefeated he's a fighter he's a fighter
I don't know what he looks like but you
got to use everything in my opinion like
I can't be with Pauly Shore
don't say anything up you [ __ ] if you
[ __ ] ever [ __ ] say his name again
in this [ __ ] podcast nothing against
you don't you talking about erase erase
erase no my taste is great great I loved
did you watch all this movies cuz I
didn't tonight I love it even in the
army now all of India is like the French
Connection oh man was my favorite movie
ever
yes jury duty is like the Seven Samurai
in my opinion hey listen can I just say
something real quick Bobby before you
[ __ ] get up
and go crazy I'm not saying that my
taste what I find funny and a stand-up
comedian is not him oh it's Bob your
friend thank you so much for all the
things you've done for me and and my own
you've treated me with respect I would
not be a comic without you and your mom
thank you so much and I think you're
amazing person and I'm an amazing
comedian and an actor what my girlfriend
says it does not reflect reflect they're
strictly mine and also man that photo
with you and Fred Durst that took she
made me he ain't got off Instagram okay
anyways just answer the question for
real Bobby is that that was your answer
yes what can I do to find someone who
actually cares about me as a person
just watch she's gonna care about you I
think that she's probably you know the
fighting thing if you're not in the one
percenter of fighters you're not making
all that much money so if she doesn't
know about she's kind of a ding dong you
know like you I always say what is this
I always say date someone who's gonna
understand your lifestyle and date
someone who is going to support you so
because it's like being a fighter is
very hard you make no money you
especially like the earlier years it's a
lot on your body you know you're putting
basically your [ __ ] life at stake
right and but it's a part of your life
so you can't not tell a woman when you
meet her and you're interested that hey
this is what I'm good at because you
want to show what you're good at Conor
McGregor's life right when he was saying
to her when he was struggling or maybe
she's supporting anything yeah
she's basically bought his lottery
ticket he was a plumber when she met him
yeah but he was still had the dream of
finding right so she just so she you if
he was just a plumber but he has that
extra thing you know me it's like you
know it's like if I had no arms it's
just harder there you go this is what
you do yeah it's like
by a drink no touch yeah yeah yeah my
thing is I don't think that he should
withhold that information that he is a
fighter because you want to find a woman
who supports his craft right but he
needs to be better at screening women
he's saying that women only want him
because he's a fighter that's not true
though but then those women are easy to
scream that's also true it's like people
you know when we first started dating we
were like she's on her Instagram you're
only with him because there's a
gold-digger whatever right but it's like
really have you seen what I look like
have you seen my lifestyle she if it was
just surface she's out the way I live
but also my thoughts we smelled
Bakersfield
that's far hey he's pretty far out it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] if that Eleanor when right
did the podcast earlier today she told
the story just now right today it was
true she goes she goes one time I
thought you sabotage me because I was on
stage in the main room and you took a
[ __ ] in the main room bathroom which is
you have to go through three different
doors to get he's dead right and she
knew it cuz I she knew I took a [ __ ]
there and had left and she could smell
my [ __ ] from the stage which is [ __ ]
potent travel 10,000 yards right and
that's and she's still here what do you
think what do you think I thought it was
just a weird really weird statement that
he said I'm that's the only thing women
want me for young girls do they see
fighter and they think the only
reference they have in their mind is
like UFC immediately I mean you're an
adult you can't screen that for yourself
that makes no 25 you're a big boy you
can't screen that for yourself that's
awesome yeah wrong with you man I don't
[ __ ] me up but don't beat me
yeah it just get better at like knowing
you know types of people I think that it
comes with age it comes with experience
and if you find the wrong girl and she
[ __ ] you over that's just all part of
this that's just next time then you'll
learn better you'll know how to screen
better and it's I think that it's okay
to make
mistakes that when you're 25 and I think
it's okay to date a lot of the wrong
people at 25 so I think you should take
your chances don't withhold that
information because you're good at it
and that's something MMA is something
you should be proud of and you know
you'll you'll date shitty ones but
that's okay that's the Danny experience
yeah it's a experience like in and down
the road even when you're 40 you'll
still meet you'll come across shady
people it never ends you just it that's
just how life works sometimes you just
win it some people find their people at
25 some people don't Bobby it took 45
years to [ __ ] find for him and I to
to meet right and you know that's just
just you know trust in the in the and
the power of experience whether it's
shitty or good
[Music]
[Music]